(upbeat music)
- Good afternoon, I'm Vince Resh
and I'm chair of the
Hitchcock Lecture Series
and I want to welcome you to
the second of two lectures
that are going to be presented
by our guest this year
and we're very delighted to have her here.
Dr. Eugenie Scott is a
renowned anthropologist
and science educator.
She was the executive director
for the National Center for
Science Education since 1986
and until her retirement in
2014 and as many of you know,
the center is a nonprofit
organization based in Oakland
whose stated mission is to defend
the integrity of science education
against ideological interference.
And for those you that were lucky enough
to hear the lecture yesterday,
she talked very, very
brilliantly about two topics
which are always supposed to
keep out of our conversations,
how science and religion,
sorry, politics and religion
can influence science.
And just a brilliant lecture.
She received her BS and MS degrees
from the University of Wisconsin Milwaukee
at a pHD in biological anthropology
from the University of Missouri.
She's taught at the
University of Kentucky,
University of Colorado, San Jose State
and California State East Bay.
Now, the National Center
for Science Education,
Dr. Scott's work centered on
attempts to teach evolution
as simply one of a series of
hypotheses about human origins.
Such as efforts to teach creation science,
and intelligent design in
American public schools.
In 2005, Dr. Scott and her staff worked
on the side of the
plaintiffs in the well known
Kitzmiller versus Dover
Area School District case.
And the court famously ruled
that intelligent design
was indeed a form of creationism
and therefore it's teaching,
violated the establishment clause
of the first amendment
of the US Constitution.
Now, the Hitchcock Lecture Series
is quite a well known series has gone on
and there's a detailed history of it
that I'd recommend that you look at.
Likewise, there's a more
detailed biography of Dr. Scott
that you may want to read
after the lecture is over.
So I want to conclude with 2010,
the National Academy of
Science awarded Dr. Scott,
the public welfare medal for
extraordinary use of science
for the public good.
Her second lecture which will be given now
is entitled Evolution and
Creationism as Science and Myth.
I also to thank Dr Bill Lineker
who as he's done many times,
explained the meaning of
that second graph up there,
which is one of Darwin's first attempts
at drawing an evolutionary tree
or what we now call today a phylogeny.
So I wish you'd all join me
in welcoming Dr. Eugenie Scott
for her second lecture and certainly,
we're very lucky to have her here.
(applause)
- Thank you.
Thank you Vincent.
It really is such a
high honor to be invited
to be a Hitchcock Lecture.
When I got the letter,
I was just blown away.
My predecessors in this position
have been such extraordinary scholars
and internationally known brilliant minds.
So because this is such a very high honor
and because it's four
o'clock in the afternoon,
I'm going to read you a bedtime story.
(laughs)
Please do not fall asleep
because I have a purpose in mind for this.
Once upon a time, there
was a steam engine.
It was pulling a train full of toys
and food for the good
little girls and boys
on the other side of the mountain.
Then suddenly, the train stopped.
Her wheels just wouldn't turn anymore.
So the clown and the toys started
looking for another engine
to take them over the mountain.
They asked a big passenger train,
"Please, would you take
us over the mountain
"for the good little girls and boys?"
"No," said the passenger train.
"I am much too grand
for the likes of you."
Then they saw a powerful freight train.
"Would you please pull
us over the mountain
"for the good little boys and girls?"
"No," said the freight train.
"I am much too powerful and important
"to pull the likes of you."
Then they saw a little old train
and asked if it would pull
them over the mountains.
"No," said the little little train.
"I am too old and tired
to go over the mountain.
"I cannot help you."
The toys didn't know what to do.
Then the little blue engine
came up to them and asked,
"What is the matter my friends?"
"Oh, little blue engine,
"would you please pull
us over the mountain?
"The good little girls and boys
"won't have any toys to play with
"or good food to eat if you don't.
"Please help us."
The little blue engine explained
that she had never been over the mountain
and usually, she was just asked
to switch trains in the yard.
"I'm not very big, but I will try
"to take you over the mountain."
So she hitched herself to the train.
It was a very steep mountain
but the little blue engine
kept saying to herself,
I think I can, I think
I can, I think I can.
And slowly and with great effort,
they started up the track and at last,
they reached the top of the mountain.
The little train did it.
Down to the children in
the valley, they went.
Now the good little girls
and boys would have toys
and good food to eat.
The little blue train saying to herself,
I thought I could, I thought
I could, I thought I could.
And if you think the
little engine that could
is about talking steam engines,
you're missing the point.
The little engine that could
is about the importance of perseverance,
having confidence, being
willing to give it your all.
It's an American inculturation myth.
It's a classic American myth.
If the Hopis or the Iropish
were writing a story for children
about getting a train over a mountain,
all the toys would get out of the train
and collectively and cooperatively
push the train over the mountains.
This is an American enculturation myth.
In the beginning, God
created heaven and earth
and the earth was without form
and void and darkness was
upon the face of the deep.
And the spirit of God moved
upon the face of the waters.
And God said, "Let there be
light," and there was light.
And God saw the light that it was good.
And God divided the
light from the darkness,
called the light day and
the darkness he called night
and the evening and the
morning were the first day.
And God said, "Let there be a firmament
"in the midst of the waters
"and let it divide the
waters from the waters,"
And God made the firmament
and divided the waters
which were under the
firmament from the waters
which were above the
firmament and it was so.
And God called the firmament heaven
and the evening and the
morning where the second day.
And God said, "Let the
waters under the heaven
"be gathered together into one place
"and let the dry land
appear," and it was so.
And God called the dry land earth
and the gathering together
of the waters, he called seas
and God saw that it was good and God said,
"Let the earth bring forth grass,
"the herb yielding seed and the fruit tree
"yielding fruit after
its kind," and it was so.
And the evening and the
morning were the third day.
Well, I suspect you have a
pretty good idea how this ends.
Most Americans are quite familiar
with the Genesis creation story.
Day four, God creates the
sun, the moon and the stars.
Day five He creates sea
creatures and birds.
Day six he creates people and mammals.
And all of creation is good.
Things go okay for a while,
but then Adam and Eve are
tempted by the serpent
and disobey God
and they are driven
from the garden of Eden.
Now the Genesis story is no
more about talking snakes
than the Little Engine that could
is about talking steam engines.
Both are examples of what
folklorists called myth
and myths are really important.
One dictionary definition
of myth is falsehood,
but it's not important
whether myths are factual.
In fact, most of the time they aren't
which doesn't lessen their importance.
Let me surprise you, as a
scientist and a humanist,
I will say that to a people,
myths are more important than facts.
And now I better explain
what it mean by myth.
The study of mythology
crosses many borders.
Folklore and literature certainly,
but also sociology and anthropology.
And popular speech again, the
synonym of myth is falsehood.
To a folklorist though,
myths are the symbolic representation
of important cultural values to a people.
They are especially important
in non literate cultures
where cultural values have
to be transmitted orally,
but they also occur in
modern industrial countries.
They have many purposes.
They might explain the
origin of the people
or establish rights to land
or to objects or rituals
for tribe or kin groups.
Myths may be incorporated into rituals
that remind people of the relationships
of their group to other groups
or relationships within the society.
They may also be art forms.
Beowulf, the Odyssey, the Norse editors.
These are all art forms,
but highly mythic.
They represent values which are important
to the people who have developed them.
And they are a way of promoting
the continuity of a culture.
And of course, myths
diffuse from group to group.
They're taken apart, they're rearranged,
they're synchrotized
with a cultural elements
just like every other aspect of culture.
But the big takeaway here
is that myths are not false.
They are representative and
they tell important truths
about a people.
Myths are not supposed
to be taken literally.
You're not supposed to
believe that Ragged Dick
was a real person.
Ragged Dick is a character
in a popular series of books
written by the late 19th
century author Horatio Alger.
Who's heard of Horatio Alger stories?
Practically every hand went up.
Well, Ragged Dick and his fellow heroes
were plucky poor boys who
through their strong character
and basic decency, managed
to pull themselves up
from poor levels of society
to the middle class.
The Horatio Alger myth symbolizes
a very classic American secular myth,
Rags to Riches.
Anybody can succeed, anybody
can pull themselves up
by their bootstraps
and this is a very, very
powerful American myth.
And there are individuals who succeed
against very remarkably difficult odds.
People like Ben Carson or
people like George Soros.
Actually the statistics will show
that a movement in the United
States from class to class,
social mobility is
actually less than it is
in much of Europe, but it is nonetheless,
an American myth that we can do that.
Periodically over the years,
the Horatio Alger myth
influences American social welfare policy
where poor and working class individuals
are expected to bootstrap themselves up
with minimal help from
society and government.
But no one thinks that
Ragged Dick is a real person.
Ragged Dick is symbolic.
The power of myth is its symbolism.
It's not true in the literal sense
but it's true in the
meaning that it conveys.
The little engine that could
and Horatio Alger stories
are mythic narratives that illustrate
American secular values,
the value of individuality,
hard work, perseverance and
confidence on the one hand
and the importance of
individual character for success
on the other.
They're not factual, but they are true
in that they reflect American values.
Now, myths are not ordinary narratives.
They themselves are ritualized.
There's a number of language conventions
associated with myths.
There's often an
introduction that tells you,
oh, I'm in the land of myth now.
I'm not supposed to believe
that there's actually fairy godmothers.
Once upon a time,
in the beginning, long, long
ago in a galaxy far away.
(laughs)
Myths usually have repetitive elements.
The toys asked three engines
and it's the fourth engine
that manages to solve the problem.
In the other children's
book, The Little Red Hen,
the hen asks the other animals,
who will help me plant the wheat?
Not I, said the pig,
not I, said the cow,
not I, said the dog.
This repetition is something
that's very common.
And the morning and the
evening were the first day
and the morning and the
evening were the second day.
So there are linguistic conventions
that signal that you are
in the world of myth.
Another characteristic of
myth that sets it apart
from other narrative is that
it often deals with supernatural elements.
Characters or circumstances
that would not be typically encountered.
Gods or demons or talking steam engines.
Or as with the Horatio Alger myth,
rich beneficiaries who appear
(mumbles)
To solve the problems for you.
Until I was preparing this talk,
I never actually looked at
the Horatio Alger books.
They're awful.
(laughs)
I can kind of see why nobody
really reads them anymore
but everybody knows the Horatio Alger myth
because the mythical continues
even without the representation
in this series of books.
But what usually happens
in the Horatio Alger books
is you have this plucky poor boy
who's working very, very hard,
but he's just a decent,
honest, wonderful person
and this rich man comes along
and gives him a job and then he succeeds.
Or the rich man comes along
and marries Ragged Dick
to his daughter or something.
Yeah, like that's gonna happen real often,
but so there are supernatural
things that happen in myths.
So since the topic of tonight is actually
the Creationism and Evolution Issue,
how does myth relate to
creation and evolution?
Well, Bible scholars have
ascertained that the old testament
was written over a period of
centuries by many individuals
and was influenced by many factors.
The two major religions.
There are two major religions
that consider it sacred.
Jews look at Genesis as establishing
the descendants of Abraham
as the chosen people
and focus on the promise of
restoration of the Jewish people
to the promised land.
Christians have a different focus,
which I'll discuss in more
detail later on in the talk.
But what did Genesis signify
to the ancient Hebrews
rather than to modern Christians and Jews?
Several Christian and Jewish theologians
have considered what the
Genesis creation story
would have meant to the
people who set it down
2,500 to 3000 years ago.
Now, think about this.
Who were the ancient Hebrews?
They were a pretty small tribe
in the middle of a very
busy part of the world.
After all, the geographically
the Middle East
is this crossroads of three continents.
So there are a lot of
other tribal groups around
and the Hebrews were this
little monotheistic dot
in the middle of all these
polytheistic religions.
The Syrians, the
Babylonians, the Persians,
the Egyptians, and worst of all,
all of these other, larger,
more powerful entities
periodically conquered the poor Hebrews.
So you can imagine the
pressure on the Hebrews
to maintain their monotheism
in the middle of all of this pressure
from especially conquering
nations to adopt their religion,
to adopt their habits and so forth.
Maintaining monotheism
and avoiding syncretism
was the issue for the Hebrews.
And it's all over the Old Testaments.
Moses's commandments begin,
thou shalt have no other gods before thee.
Well, this isn't a big issue
in the 20th and 21st century.
It wasn't even a big issue
in the eighth century,
but it was a real big issue
for the ancient Hebrews.
In the King James
version, it's followed by,
thou shalt not make unto
thee any graven image.
Although we're not really big
into graven images these days either,
but historically from the
standpoint of the ancient Hebrews,
these were things that the
neighbors of the Hebrews
were doing, the whole
business about the golden calf
when the tablets were being
brought down and so forth.
Keeping their identity
as the chosen people,
as the Hebrews as opposed to adopting
all of these cultural
practices of their neighbors.
This was the big issue for the Hebrews.
Now, how do people do this?
How do you keep your identity?
Well, one way is through myth.
One way is through having
stories, having rituals,
stories that are embedded into rituals
that you can pass on to next generations
that you can use to remind
the people in your group,
in your tribe that this is who we are
and this is why we are important.
How does the creation story in Genesis
tell us what was important
to the ancient Hebrews?
The late Presbyterian
theologian Conrad Hyres
has I think, a very
interesting perspective
on what Genesis might have
meant to the ancient Hebrews
and he views it as a powerful myth
in this symbolic sense that
I've been talking about myth.
To remind the Jews that they were people
who were indeed different
from their neighbors
and better than their neighbors
because their God was the superior God
and they were this powerful
God's chosen people.
The ancient Hebrews distinguish themselves
from the neighbors and kept their identity
by stressing in Genesis
the power of their God
over other gods.
So on day one, God creates light
and separates light from darkness.
Thus are the gods of light
and darkness vanquished.
On day two, God creates
the heavens and the earth.
Thus vanquishing sky gods and earth gods.
On day three, God creates the
oceans, lands and vegetation,
thus making sea and vegetation
divinities redundant.
Day four, God creates
the sun, moons and stars,
therefore establishing his superiority
over the deities associated
with those heavenly bodies,
which were of course widely worshiped
by the people surrounding the Hebrews.
Days five and six, he
takes away the divinity
of the animal kingdom, and
by creating people specialty,
he takes away the divine
origin of kings and Pharaohs.
Ramesses, you're not the
son of Rah, God created you.
So our God can whoop your God
is kind of what this is all about.
The sixth day creation
story establishes Yahweh
as the one true divinity,
superior to all of the other gods.
The rest of Genesis, which
is largely the Abraham story,
establishes the special relationship
between the descendants
of Abraham, the Jews
and this very powerful omnipotent God.
So the six-day Hebrew creation story
also symbolizes the nature of God.
The Hebrew God was ever present,
unlike the Sumerians or Mesopotamian gods,
Yahweh didn't originate from the actions
of some other god or preexisting force.
We're familiar with the Greeks whose gods
had a lineage.
Aronows begot Cronos, Cronos begot Zeus,
Zeus begot Athena and
all the rest of them.
But the Hebrew God just is.
He's been there since eternity.
He doesn't have a genealogy.
He doesn't even have a biography.
He just is.
He's this very powerful,
omnipotent individual.
He wills the universe into being
unlike the Mesopotamian or Sumerian gods
that require preexisting materials
to be formed into the universe,
God can just say poof, do it.
God is moral.
God knows good and evil.
The neighboring gods,
if you really take a
look at the Greek gods,
which is what we're most familiar with
probably in our culture,
we don't pay a whole lot of attention
to Sumerian gods anymore,
but we just study Greek mythology.
The Greek gods really seemed to govern
in a universe without purpose or meaning.
But God is moral, he knows good and evil.
The universe does have purpose
and meaning to the Hebrews.
God is not part of nature,
but stands outside of it
as its creator which again
contest very strongly
with the more animistic aspects
of the neighboring polytheists.
Genesis thus best reflects
the Hebrew view of nature
and of God, but it also represents
a different view of humankind
and that held by their neighbors.
God specially creates Adam
and Eve, male and female.
He created them in his image.
(mumbles)
So people are special.
They are moral beings like their creator.
They have a purpose like their creator.
They're not just random things
at the whim of idiosyncratic gods
and of course this is all tied in
with the idea of the Jews
being the chosen people.
To the ancient Hebrews, then
Genesis is about polytheism
versus monotheism and religious syncretism
versus cultural independence.
Genesis is a powerful myth
symbolizing issues of life and death,
importance to the ancient Hebrews.
It is this mythic symbolism
for modern Christians and Jews.
I'm sorry.
Genesis has mythic symbolism
for modern Christians and Jews
for different reasons,
which I will talk about
a little bit later.
It's not about talking snakes.
It's not about...
It's not meant to be taken literally.
It's myth with all the power and truth
to a people's culture
that myth represents.
Genesis certainly isn't about science
and whether humans shared common ancestry
with other organisms.
But what about myth and
science or myth and evolution?
You often hear Phillip
Johnson from Boalt Hall
once said that evolution
is the new myth of America.
The new mythology or the myth of evolution
has replaced the myth of Genesis
or sciences is the modern mythology, etc.
Well, what about sciences
myth or evolution as myth.
In the sense that I've
been using myth obviously
as a symbolic representation
of the values of a people.
Now, as I did with myth,
I need to define science.
So you at least know what I mean
when I'm talking about science today.
You may be surprised
to hear a scientist say
that science is limited way of knowing.
It is limited in that we're
only trying to explain
the natural world.
We're not trying to explain everything
that human beings are interested in.
I cannot prove to you
scientifically that Mozart
is better than Madonna or that the Beatles
are better than Bieber.
Those are not scientists...
Questions of aesthetics are
certainly not scientific issues
and there are many other issues
that need to be resolved,
matters of opinion,
dealing with values and ideologies.
They're not going to be
resolved by science either.
Whether Mr. Kavanaugh should be confirmed
as a supreme court justice
isn't a matter of science.
We could use logical arguments,
we could talk about musical complexity
when talking about the Beatles
or talking about Bieber
but that's not the same thing as science.
We could look at Mr.
Kavanauh's judicial record
on some issue or another but that's not...
The fact that you are using
empirical evidence and logic
doesn't mean you're using science
because empirical evidence and logic
is part of critical thinking in general.
I like to think of
science as the application
of critical thinking, if you will,
to explaining the natural world.
So science is limited to
explaining the natural world
and there's a second limitation
and that is that we're restricted
to explaining the natural
world through natural processes
and unlike what many people think,
this limitation of science to
only using natural processes
isn't because all scientists are atheists
because they aren't.
It's because the essence of science
is testing our explanations
against the natural worlds.
And when you think about it,
how do you test an explanation?
Notice science communication fans.
I don't use the word experiment
because when people hear
the word experiment,
they think of somebody in
a laboratory doing this
and they don't think of
these graduate students
in IB out in the field who
may also be doing experiments.
So I talk about tests
because there are a lot of different ways
we can test our explanations.
So the essence of testing an explanation
has to do with holding
constant some variables
and then letting other variables go
so you can see whether
your explanation holds.
Because science is about testing
because testing is about
holding constant variables,
we're stuck with natural causes
because those are the only
kinds we can hold constant.
My good friend Bill Thwait once suggested
if we can only invent a theometer,
then we can perhaps test
supernatural explanations
but we don't have a theometer
so we're stuck with natural causes
because those are the kinds
that we can hold constant.
So science turns out to be a method
or procedure that one follows
to find out how the natural world works.
To operate as myth, science
has to reflect important values
or ideologies of a people.
So does it?
Well if you're a scientist,
and there are some of us in the audience,
you know that there are
values within science.
There are values you're
supposed to reflect
if you do science.
You don't ignore the data
that disagrees with your explanation.
You have to be truthful in
reporting your procedures
and results so you have to be
willing to change your mind
with new data or theory and so on.
But that isn't especially
specific to science.
I would expect the same kinds of values
from an accountant, frankly.
Those are values within science.
They're not values that
science can symbolize.
There is another reason why I don't think
science makes good myth
and that is that science
doesn't reflect any particular culture.
When you think about it,
science, this methodology,
this practice of explaining
the natural world
through testing occurs in cultures
and people all over the planet
from individualistic cultures
like the United States
to more communitarian
cultures like China or India,
but they all do science the same way.
Science doesn't reflect the culture.
Well, okay.
The science studies people
will say, yes it does
but remember, I'm speaking
at a very general level here.
In general, there are certain
rules you have to follow.
If you don't test your explanation,
you're not going to get it
published in Science Magazine
and PNS and the other outlets.
Your colleagues in science
aren't going to trust your results
if you don't follow the
rules of collecting data,
being honest about it, being
open about it, etc, etc.
Science has values itself
but science is a very
international kind of behavior,
if you will.
So it really doesn't reflect
the values of a culture
or there's no such thing as
the values of all culture.
So because science is a method,
I don't think it makes very good myth.
There is another reason why
science doesn't make good myth
and that is because science is,
it's an open ended kind of explanation.
There's a core group
of scientific concepts
that we've tested and
tested and tested and tested
and they're really not going to change.
That the earth goes around the sun.
Heliocentrism is here to stay.
We're not really going
to test that anymore.
The earth is spherical
regardless of what the flat
earthers are saying these days.
Living things have common ancestors,
laws of thermodynamics.
There are things that we
don't change our minds about
but there's a lot of things
that we're still trying to figure out
and it's perfectly
acceptable within science
to change our minds
about our explanations.
That's a feature, not a bug.
A good friend of mine Met
Kurtmel was once asked,
why did you become a scientist?
And he wrote, "As an adolescent,
I aspired to lasting fame.
"I craved factual certainty
"and I thirsted for a
meaningful vision of human life,
"so I became a scientist."
This is like becoming an
archbishop so you can meet girls.
So science is continually changing
though again, that doesn't
mean that it's unreliable
because there are these
core concepts of science
that really don't change,
but the open-endedness, the
changeability of science,
although it is very valuable
for understanding the natural world,
makes science very poor myth.
Ashley Montagu once described science
as truth without certainty,
which I like that phrase a lot.
The values and truths of a culture's myth,
needs stability and continuity.
Science doesn't give you that.
So science really doesn't make good myth.
So I would conclude that
science is very good
for explaining the natural
world, but it's lousy myth.
However powerful and
inspiring science can be,
it can't in itself produced
culturally sustaining myths.
Well, what about evolution?
Is it mythical?
Can evolution symbolize a worldview
or values important to us?
Let's take a look at evolution.
Evolution is a three part idea.
There's the big idea of evolution,
which is that living things
have common ancestors.
We and all other living
things on the planet
have descended with modification
from common ancestors.
There's also the patterns of evolution.
How did the tree of life split and branch
and die through time?
There's also the mechanisms
or processes of evolution.
The factors that bring about evolution
and of course these are
things like natural selection,
nonselective methods, development
and so forth and so on,
speciation and the like.
Now, evolution consists of the big idea,
the pattern and the process.
Let's take a look at each
of these components in turn
and consider how they work as myth
or whether they could function as myth.
Well, when we look at
patterns of evolution,
I think we see very
little mythic inspiration.
Whether pandas are bears or raccoons
or whether the thanksgiving Turkey
is descended from a dinosaur
isn't going to be much use
in symbolizing cultural values.
So certainly the patterns of
evolution isn't going to work.
The mechanisms or processes of evolution,
I think we have a little more
possibility for myth here
especially the concept
of natural selection.
There's a rather long history of ideology
seizing on natural selection
to support their views.
Capitalists like Andrew Carnegie
promoted evolution by natural selection
to promote capitalism.
Henry Russell Wallace was a socialist.
He supported his views
with natural selection.
Peter Kropotkin argued for anarchy
using evolution and natural selection
and Vernon Kellogg argued for pacifism.
Now think about that.
Capitalism, socialism,
anarchy and pacifism.
These all are inspired
by natural selection.
It's kind of like the
blind man and the elephant.
They're sort of taking what they want
to support their particular point of view.
I think the ideology comes first
and these men and others following them,
are taking a powerful scientific idea
and using it to support their
particular ideological views.
But I don't think
there's anything inherent
in natural selection that would lead you
to either capitalism,
socialism, pacifism or anarchy.
So I would argue that despite efforts,
natural selection, other
mechanisms of evolution
don't really work as myth either.
Well, what about the big
idea of common ancestry?
Okay, here's where we
get some mythic purchase.
The idea that we and all living
things have common ancestors
is a very powerful scientific idea
and it's also a very
powerful philosophical idea.
It also happens to be
scientifically correct
because given all the
evidence that we have,
I'd contend that the most
powerful element in evolution
as mythic is its ability to provide us
a sense of place in the universe,
a view of where we as human
beings and individuals
stand relative to everything else.
On the other hand, myths
are often reflective
of moral values and ethical
values in the society
and common ancestry just
like all the rest of science
isn't very good as a moral guide.
Science tells you that coyotes
kill rats and house cats.
It doesn't tell you whether
that is good or bad.
As Thomas Henry Huxley said,
science tells you what
is not what should be.
If you believe that because
something is natural,
it is therefore good,
you need to think that
through a little further.
Hueman said it even before Huxley.
Ought does not follow from is.
There are both theistic
as well as nontheistic
uses of evolution as myth.
Let's look at some of
the theistic versions.
First beginning with the creationists.
Now creationists follow
a more conservative form
of Christianity than do Catholics
or mainstream protestants.
Modern conservative Christians,
don't look at Genesis like
the ancient Hebrews did.
To them, Genesis isn't
about maintaining monotheism
and identifying the Jews
as the chosen people.
Christianity in general is more concerned
with the new testament and creationists
look at the old testament
as foreshadowing the appearance of Christ.
To conservative Christians,
God creates a perfect world
and perfect humans in the garden of Eden.
People are special to God
and are required to worship and obey him.
The disobedience of Adam and Eve
for eating from the tree of
the knowledge of good and evil
causes them to be sent out from the garden
to make their own way, and
that brings pain and suffering
and death into the world, which of course
were not present in the garden of Eden.
The separation from God is felt to be
the greatest punishment
and it is only reversed
according to conservative Christians,
by the sacrifice of Jesus who dies
to atone for the sin of Adam.
In fact, Paul in the new
testament refers to Jesus
as the new Adam and the second Adam.
To conservative Christians,
the old testament is
firmly connected to the new
and events of the old testament
are necessary for the coming of Jesus
and of course with the
sacrifice of Jesus on the cross,
salvation is restored.
So to Christians, Genesis
is really important
and it is mythic in a very different way
than it was to the ancient Hebrews.
As religiously conservative Christians
creationists believed that
the bible is not only true,
but it is a unified whole.
In this cartoon from answers in Genesis,
the reader says, "The six
day creation issue in Genesis
"isn't important to scripture.
"I'll just take the six days out."
And finds that the whole
bible unravels as a result.
So anything that challenges Genesis,
challenges the entire bible.
Genesis to revelations is all one piece
and evolution is incompatible
with the literal reading of Genesis.
That's just full stop.
If an individual
interprets the bible as six
24 hour days of creation,
a short period of time ago,
that cannot be accommodated
with any science really,
but certainly not with evolution,
but that is not the
mainstream Christian theology.
So if evolution is true,
believe conservative Christians,
then Genesis and the entire
bible have to be false.
That means there's no God,
and if there's no God,
there is no salvation.
There's a direct line from the
creation to the sin of Adam
to the death of Jesus on the cross,
to the possibility of redemption
and salvation and revelations.
A child who accepts evolution
is endangering his very soul.
They will not be saved.
So it's not difficult to see
why parents object so strongly
to evolution being taught in schools.
In addition to the loss
of salvation though,
they believe that without
religion to guide us,
we will not behave morally
with terrible consequences for society.
Without God, there's no
morality, they believe
so people will not know how to act.
The caption says, if this is
what Johnny can read and write,
then this news shows
that Johnny really
understands his lessons.
Without the bible and God as moral rudder,
they believe we will have no guidance.
This is one of my favorite graphics
from the creationist literature.
It is from an old conference
of younger creationists
held in the 1990s and you can see here
very dreadful things on the
branches of this tree of evil.
Racism, humanism, paganism,
nazi-ism, abortion,
euthanasia, drug culture,
radical feminist movement.
Terrible things.
And evolution is the foundation
for all of these terrible societal ills.
And here's the creation science message
that's going to get rid of evolution
and therefore society will be restored
to a more edenic, a more proper form.
Henry Morris is the most
important creationist
of the 20th century, more so
than William Jennings Bryan
ever dreamed of becoming.
And he has written,
"Evolution is at the
foundation of communism,
"fascism, freudianism, social darwinism,
"behaviorism, kinsism,
materialism, atheism
and in the religious word,
modernism and neo orthodoxy.
Now, nobody laughed.
I once many years ago gave a talk
at Lexington Theological Institute.
Lexington Theological Seminary,
which is a protestant seminary
in Lexington, Kentucky
and I showed this over the top graphic
and I read that quote by Henry Morris
and I got to the part about
modernism and neo orthodoxy
and they were on the floor.
They thought that was the
funniest thing they'd ever heard.
I mean that has never been
before or since a laugh line,
but it was to these seminarians.
They thought that that
was the funniest thing
that they heard in a long time.
Now, modernism and neo orthodoxy
refers to two schools
of Christian theology,
which religiously conservative
Christians reject.
Modernism arose out of 19th century
biblical criticism where
the bible was viewed
as a text like any other.
The bible had a history,
it consisted of a series of manuscripts
which were written by different
people at different time.
It was cobbled together,
there were contradictions.
There were conferences where they decided
which books to leave in,
which ones to leave out
and once you understand that
the bible has a history,
it wasn't just dictated by
the Almighty to ascribe,
that makes you look at at your
holy text quite differently.
And of course this is true
of seminary trained religious
professionals in Christianity.
The bible is a human document
with a history and errors.
You treat it differently
than if you believe
that every word was dictated by God.
Now, like all academic disciplines,
Christian theology has a very large number
of intellectual movements
of which modernism in the
orthodoxy are only two.
Very many postmodernists
theological movements
incorporate evolution and other sciences
into their theology.
Process theology is a view held
by the catholic theologian, John Haught.
Those of you who are
Kitzmiller versus Dover fans
might recognize a Jack Haught
as the theologian that we brought in
as a witness for the good
guy side, if I may say so.
He was incredibly articulate.
He was very impressive
and the judge mentioned,
how enlightening he felt that
John Haught's testimony was.
A very famous geneticist
named Theodocius Dbjohnski,
a Russian man who came
to the United States
many, many years ago a wrote an article,
the title of which has become
an aphorism in biology.
He said, nothing in biology makes sense
except in the light of evolution.
Well, Jack Haught has written
that nothing in theology
makes sense except in
the light of evolution.
Regarding creation and process theology,
God did not create in six
days and rest on the seventh
rather than creatio ex nihalo
rather than creation from nothing,
they believe in creatio
continuo, continuous creation.
God continues to create through
the process of evolution.
So the world and the universe
is expected to change
rather than to remain
static after six days.
Process theology is quite
accepting of evolution
and here is where the mythic potential
is well expressed among theorists.
Lutheran, theologian, Philip Hefner,
who is just as jolly as
he looks in that picture.
He's a delightful man
also looks at human beings
as having been created by God
in the sense of having emerged
through the process of evolution
but that creation continues
through the process of evolution.
When Phillip talks about Imago Dei
the image of God, he's expressing the idea
that as God is creative,
so are human beings.
We creative creatures are made
in the image of a creative God.
So humans, thus are co-creators with God,
which gives us considerable opportunity
and consequent responsibility
to affect both ourselves
as well as the other organisms
with which we share this planet.
Ted Peters, who is a Lutheran theologian
at the Lutheran School of
Religion here in Berkeley
and Martinez Hewlett
share some of these views,
especially that creation continues.
It didn't stop after six days.
They also contend that much
as evolutionary biology
has both adaptive evolution
through natural selection
as well as neutral evolution
through genetic drift
that God can create both through design
as well as through chance,
and they don't believe
that God is controlling
every single little random
element in the universe.
That God allows the universe
to evolve along a path.
At the Center for Theology
and the Natural Sciences
around the corner from here,
Robert John Russell also
has written extensively
of the role of chance in evolution
and how it's compatible
with this view of God.
Now, these theologians
take a very different view
on subjects like sociobiology or stem cell
or genetic modification research
as God's created co-creators.
We have the ability to affect evolution,
hence, these theologians
spend a lot of time
talking about the moral and ethical issues
regarding science and
human responsibility.
But they totally accept the science.
There is no rejection of
evolution of the science.
A couple of interesting
people are Michael Dowd
and Connie Barlow who are
the evangelists for evolution
and that they are ministers.
They deliberately take the
sweep of the epic of evolution
and turn it to theological purposes.
Their position is that our common ancestry
with all other human
beings makes us indeed
our brother's keepers and
that we should be doing
our utmost to make the lives
of our fellow human beings
healthier, more educated
and more comfortable.
Social justice issues also come into play.
We need to live in a more
just and peaceful world.
The common ancestry of humans
with all other creatures
makes us kin to our
fellow living organisms
and gives us a responsibility to them
and the planet on which we all depend.
Evolution places humans in nature
in a very different way than does
the interpretation of Genesis
called dominion theology.
If you remember in genesis,
God gives Adam and Eve,
mostly Adam dominion over the animals
but he also tells them
to steward the garden
and some Christians emphasize
the stewardship theology,
some emphasize the dominion theology.
And theists are not alone
in finding that evolution
has a great deal to say
about their faith tradition.
There is a huge amount
of Christian theology
around evolution, compatible
with their view of God
and God's action in the world.
Now, non theists, people
who do not believe in God,
materialists of various kinds
have also used evolution
from mythic representation
at least as much if not more
than have Christian theologians.
Religious naturalism is one manifestation
of how evolution is used to
provide a sense of purpose
and meaning and place in nature,
but within a scientific rather
than a theistic context.
Religious naturalists often will embrace
other human enterprises
in addition to science
such as literature, art or music
in a quest for meaning and worldview.
Biologists Ursula Goodenough's,
Sacred Depths of Nature
is an example of this
and looks at the history of the
universe chapter by chapter.
She starts with the big
bang and works all the way
through formation of the planet,
evolution of living things
on earth and human evolution.
And then in a separate
section of the book,
she talks about her
personal interpretations
in a spiritual sense of what this sweep
of the epic of evolution means to her
in terms of her view
of her place in nature.
As Darwin himself said,
there is grand jury
in this view of life
which the religious naturalists embrace.
Now, most religious
naturalists are naturalists
in the sense that they are not theists.
They don't include the
concept of the supernatural,
although there are some
theists within the movement.
But the theists who are
embracing religious naturalism
tend to be from the deistic
end of the spectrum.
Their god is not god that interacts
and intervenes very much in the world.
Religious naturalists seemed
to share certain values
inspired by the epic of evolution.
The common origins of all living things
suggest that there is
a unity to all of life.
Religious naturalists
rarely, I haven't seen one,
embrace the idea of human exceptionalism.
Humans are rather embedded
within this matrix
of other living creatures
that are this product of
evolution just as are we.
Obviously there is a
strong ecological component
to most religious
naturalism and of course,
it grows out of this
idea of common ancestry
with all other things.
Similarly, since all humans
are closely related to one another
and descended from common ancestors,
relatively recently, we
have a responsibility
to our fellow human beings to indeed
be our brother's keeper.
For religious naturalists,
I think the strongest expression of myth
is to be provided again,
providing a sense of place
in the universe.
Because of the epic of evolution,
they believe you are a human being
who is part of a web of connectedness
with every other living thing
and are composed of the same stardust
that makes up the cosmos.
Evolution does this for nonbelievers
substituting for religiously based myths.
The biologist E.O. Wilson has said
the evolutionary epic is
probably the best myth
we will ever have and he's not using myth
as a synonym for falsehood.
So what does this have to do
with the creation and evolution conflicts?
That was a lot of stuff about
myths, science and religion.
So let's get back to what I promised you
I would talk about eventually.
First of all, there
remains a lot of opposition
to evolution by our fellow citizens.
The science and engineering indicators
is a national research council document
that's put out every two
years and they survey
adult Americans and their
views of a number of things
including questions about evolution.
They tested a revised version
of the evolution question in 2012.
First asking the traditional question,
human beings as we know them today,
developed from earlier species of animals
and they got the traditional
response about 48%.
Then in the same with
another part of the sample,
they inserted according to evolution
human beings as we know them today,
developed from earlier
species of animals, 72%.
So this suggests that people
know what evolution is
but they're not buying it.
The National Center for Science Education
tracks anti-science legislation,
anti evolution, anti climate change,
legislation, science standard
controversies every year.
2018 wasn't a real banner year.
It's only a handful of
bills and controversies.
2017 was a banner year,
a whole lot longer list.
Fortunately, only two of these past,
although that's two, too many.
Problems surrounding the
teaching of evolution
is a separate topic that I don't have time
to go into it today, but suffice to say
that NCSE continues to have its hands full
coping with these challenges.
If you ask creationists
why they reject evolution,
they'll give you one or
more of three reasons.
We call them the pillars of creationism.
They don't believe it's
supported by science,
they don't believe that evolution
is compatible with their religious views
and it's only fair to teach
evolution and creationism
because so many people
don't want evolution taught.
A variant of the fairness argument
is that it's good pedagogy.
Give the students creation and evolution
and let them decide.
And this is a critical thinking argument.
That's not a good argument.
If we were going to try to
persuade the creationists
that their children should
learn evolution in school,
how would you go about it?
Well, it's true that the
science of creation science
is really wrong.
I mean I love talking
about creation science
because it is so broke and
the science is just so zany.
They believe that Grand Canyon,
all 4,000 layers of
sediment in Grand Canyon,
sandstones, siltstone,
limestone, mudstone,
all kinds of different layers,
4,000 feet of layers,
thousands of different beds
that all of that was laid down
by the receding waters of Noah's flood.
And then this huge ditch
of what, about 200 miles
was cut catastrophically
by a huge body of water
that rushed through and miraculously
cut all this wet sediment
and left it standing
as opposed to just sort of slumping over,
which is what you'd expect
wet stuff to do anyway.
Anyway, the science is nuts.
I mean there is no known geology
that would fit this model of Grand Canyon
and that would be true of their astronomy
and everything else.
NCSE has got lots of resources
as to why creation science is bad.
But you know, arguing factual information
is not actually going to
persuade a creationist
that their science is bad
because that's not the
most important issue.
There is considerable literature
studying decision making
that contends that factual information,
while not irrelevant, is not primary
and persuading people
to change their minds.
And I talked about this
in more detail yesterday.
If you were here yesterday, thank you.
I'm not going to repeat
it, but in general,
for our purposes, lots of these concepts
from the psychology of belief literature
explaining why factual
knowledge is rejected,
they all deal with looking
at factual knowledge
through an ideological values
or a group identification filter.
And the filter comes first and usually,
that keeps the correct
information, shall we say,
from being accepted.
Values, ideology and identification
are precisely the elements of myth.
Myth is powerful and creationism is mythic
in exactly this fashion.
It reinforces the values, ideology
and identification of
conservative Christians.
It's not a surprise then that creationists
are resistant to accepting evolution.
If evolution is true, they lose big.
Obviously they're not going
to just suddenly decide.
Still, evolution needs to be taught
so that students are
scientifically literate.
How can we make this happen?
I see a short term solution
and a longterm solution.
The longterm solution relies
on evolution, if you will,
that like the rest of Christianity,
conservative Christians
will gradually moderate
their views regarding evolution.
The National Center for Science Education
Voices for Evolution book
lists statements from
religious organizations
and other institutions that encourage
the teaching of evolution in schools.
These are catholic and
mainstream protestants
and Jewish groups.
Theistic evolution, the
theological position
that evolution occurred, it
was part of God's plan, etc
is the majority view
in Christianity today.
It's the theologically
conservative denominations
that have problems with evolution.
Most Baptists, Pentecostalists,
Holiness groups, Charismatics,
Seventh Day Adventists,
Jehovah's witnesses, and the like.
But this is not a solid block.
There are evangelical Christians
who have worked diligently
to see that evolution gets
taught in their local communities
and some national
evangelical organizations
that are very friendly to evolution.
Biologos is an online evangelical
Christian organization
and they discuss a variety
of views of evolution,
believing that it can be harmonized
with their version of Christianity.
They talk about the
harmony between science
and biblical faith as we present
an evolutionary understanding
of God's creation.
Another evangelical Christian organization
is the American Scientific Affiliation
which similarly supports
the teaching of evolution in schools.
The longterm solution to
the anti evolution problem
in the United States is
for these organizations
and others and individually
evangelical Christians
to influence their fellow
conservative Christians
and persuade them that one
can be a faithful evangelical
and still accept evolution.
The way that Biologos or
the ASA would phrase it,
is that they take the bible
seriously, but not literally.
The short term situation.
The short term solution
is to call a truce.
The big fear of conservative Christians
is that when their children
are taught evolution,
they're taught therefore there is no God.
A number of years ago, a friend of mine
who was teaching biological anthropology
at a community college in the southeast,
we were talking on the phone
and she said that she had
these kids in her class.
Young adults, these students
that are undergraduates
in her class had never
learned evolution at all.
Full stop.
Their are teachers they'd
just skip those chapters.
These kids were tabula rasa.
The only thing they knew about evolution
was what they learned on
the street, so to speak.
This is college, this is
physical anthropology, right?
So day one you get evolution
and so she just taught her
class matter of factly,
like she taught anyplace else
and after a couple of weeks,
a couple of these kids came
to talk to her after class
and they said, well, of course
species change through time.
You mean that's evolution?
We thought evolution meant
you can't believe in God.
I have lots and lots of stories
like that from high school
as well as university teachers.
So I would like to assuage
the concerns of parents
that when their kid walks into,
especially a high school classroom,
there is not a teacher there saying,
okay, take your religion and shove it.
This just doesn't happen.
Survey research has
shown that K-12 teachers
show the same range of religious adherence
as other Americans.
In other words, they're highly religious
about 80 plus percent
of them believe in God,
most of them are Christian.
It's highly unlikely
that high school teachers
are telling kids that they have to choose
between their faith and science.
That just is something that
they shouldn't worry about.
The truce is that students,
even those whose parents
don't accept evolution,
need to understand evolution
in order to be scientifically literate
and if we can assuage the concerns
of conservative Christian
parents that indeed,
no one is telling their children
that they have to give up
their faith to study science,
we may be able to teach evolution
with reduced opposition.
We teach good science at the
college and high school level
and we leave the door open
to a believing student
for that student to
engage with that science
however that student wishes.
I was talking with a
high school teacher today
who was a graduate student here
and he was mentioning,
we were talking about
how do you deal with the students
who come into your class
and the fingers are
wedged tightly in the ear
because they're afraid
that they're going to have
to believe in evolution
when they hear you talk.
And his solution was one that I've heard
from many, many teachers and
I think it's very effective.
His solution was to say, okay,
I just want you to learn it.
You can accept it or
reject it, that's your call
but you need to learn it and
you need to pass the test.
And those weren't his words,
but you basically can hear the
fingers fly out of the ears
with a loud popping noise
because the students all of a sudden go,
I don't have to believe.
An interesting thing happens.
The students find out that evolution
doesn't actually hurt them.
Of course, species change through time.
They find that evolution doesn't mean
you can't believe in God.
Evolution means that living
things have common ancestors.
And look, we can show you the genetic
and other evolutionary processes
which bring this change about
which is a very different
view than they came in.
But they can't listen to the science
as long as they've got the
fingers stuck firmly in the ears.
Getting the fingers out of
the ears is a major need.
So we on the teaching side of things,
whether college or K-12,
teach good science,
leave the door open to students of faith
to continue believing if they choose.
It's not the job of the K-12
or the college professor
to change the religious views of students.
That said, I've been in the
creation and evolution business
for long enough to know that
there are no quick fixes.
We are in this for the long haul.
The longterm change is
going to take a while
and so will the short term change.
And because there aren't any quick fixes,
the National Center for Science Education
is in it for the long haul too.
Please do go to the website ncse.com.
You're going to find
a lot more information
on the creation and evolution controversy
as well as the parallel one
over teaching climate change
and you'll find some very good suggestions
for what you can do about it,
including joining the National
Center for Science Education,
which I hope you will do.
Again, children's
stories not withstanding,
I was very highly honored this year
to be a Hitchcock lecturer
and I thank you very much
for coming to hear me
on this really quite lovely day.
Thank you.
(applause)
- Unless you've been a biology teacher,
subject to the pressures of
parents and administrators,
you could not truly appreciate
what Eugenie Scott's NCSE has done
for high school, public
school science education.
She deserves every accolade
that she's received.
(applause)
- If I may, there is no way
that I as one individual
have been able to accomplish
all the wonderful things
NCSE has and there actually
are some NCSE staff
and former staff in this room as we speak
and if you wouldn't mind raising your hand
to identify yourself.
And that means you Eric.
Thank you NCSE staff.
(applause)
Garrett David, Susan Glen.
- My special concern are the creationists
who are professionals,
particularly those in engineering
and the medical professions.
When they put forth in their communities
against the teaching of evolution,
they are respected simply because
they're members of a respected profession.
Unfortunately, those I have
talked to and listened to,
do not understand science.
Many people think that engineering schools
and medical schools teach science.
That's becoming true, but traditionally
that has not been true and
they don't understand science
and when you try to talk to
them, even your approach,
they don't give you enough
respect to listen to you.
So they become an impediment.
A major impediment to
the kind of reasoning
that has worked on most lay people.
What can we do about this impediment?
- I always think of American Society
as basically being
divided into three parts,
like goal I guess.
There are people like me
who are very convinced
by the science of evolution
and it takes a whole lot
to shake that.
I mean, we're pretty convinced.
Probably most of the people in this room
are in that category.
There are those, like you were describing
who are very committed anti-evolutionists
for mostly well religious
reasons of various kinds,
but most Americans are in the middle.
They don't think about
science or religion very much
but they don't belong to denominations
that require them interpret
the bible literally.
That is really the target population.
That is really the group I think
that it is most useful to
spend your time talking to
because they are more
open to understanding
the science and understanding
how science works
and by the way, I agree with you.
I concur with you completely
on the difference between
applied scientists
like engineers and physicians
versus research scientists.
The concept of how science
works is really quite different
in both of those groups
but let's keep that
group from sliding down
into the anti evolution side
and help them understand
what a really wonderful,
life enriching phenomenon science is
and evolution within sciences
is a really fascinating field
and communicating some of that excitement
I think can help keep that middle group
from absorbing some of
the erroneous information
that is being produced
by this group down here.
Yes sir.
- I want to thank you,
thank you, thank you
for this very important presentation.
One of the things that I'm
not sure people are aware of
is that right here in Berkeley
and you mentioned the
Ted Peters and others
that we have in Berkeley,
probably the largest
group of theology schools
in the country and we need
to make these connections
between the schools of
theology and the universities.
And so people who might be interested...
So Ted Peters who you mentioned
is going to be the main organizer
of this coming summer's
institute on religion
in the nature of science meeting.
It's gonna be him with some
of the new genetics things
that Ted Peters is gonna do.
So that's IRIS, the Institute on Religion.
Anybody who's interested
in that can talk to me
and the other one you mentioned
Ursula Goodenough, is the main creator
of a new organization.
This is an online organization
with lots of talk.
Ursula's the creator of
Religious Naturalism Association.
So if anybody wants to
join that email group,
you can see me afterwards and
I can add you to the list.
So thank you, thank you.
- Thank you for that information.
Yes sir.
- I'm Lawrence.
I was expecting to speak a little more
about the climate change issue
and not totally about
evolution, but that's fine.
- I did more of that yesterday.
- Yes.
Well I'm thinking that there's a group
for disrupting the whole concept of time
which is shared by both the religionists
and the scientists here, which is that
causalities moves forward,
things in the past
cause things in the future.
Once you get down into deep science,
you can see that causality
could go both ways
and there's the deep
question of consciousness
and that once one gets into these deep
philosophical scientific issues,
it's going to provide a disruption
completely to the common
concept of time here.
See some major changes in all this thing,
but I really enjoy your covering it
at this level of shared concept of time.
- Thank you.
Yes ma'am.
- Thank you so much.
It was really inspiring.
My question is more how can
we get scientists to do more
to engage this middle group
that you were talking about?
I was on Sunday at an open house
or whatever you want to
call it, off the IGI,
the Innovative Genomics
Institute here in Berkeley
and it was fascinating,
absolutely fascinating
how they did this in a
way that engaged families
even with small children,
to show them how they could extract DNA
from strawberries, for example,
how they could build DNA with
using little marshmallows
and licorice strings and
so on and toothpicks.
And I thought, what a great approach.
You know, they had
planned for two lab tours.
They had to organize nine within
those two and a half hours
or three hours that they were open.
So what could the NCSE do
to get more direct connection
between these outstanding scientists
and the public so that there
isn't this barrier, this fear?
Thank you.
- Thank you.
Yes I love the idea of scientists
reaching out to the public
and I think it's something
that's increased.
In the last 10 years
has seen a huge change
in precisely that
The AAAS, the American Association
for the Advancement of Science.
They publish Science Magazine.
The largest professional
scientist organization
in the world, probably
20,000 plus members.
AAAS every year at its annual meeting
has workshops and sessions
for helping scientists
communicate their ideas
better with the public.
They're really encouraging
this kind of outreach
and I'd love to see it expand.
I will remind everybody that I'm retired.
I no longer...
I can promote NCSE certainly,
but I am not a decision maker there.
So I can't speak for what they might do
to encourage scientists to do more.
My feeling is that NCSE has always been
the mouse that roared.
It's a very tiny organization
that has a hugely disproportionate effect,
mostly because we work with lots of allies
and get them to do all the work
but we're very important.
But it's also a pretty tiny organization
with a pretty tiny budget and it's limited
with how much it can do.
For them to try to develop
a scientist network
to do the kind of very worthwhile
thing you're suggesting
would I think require new staff,
new budgeting and something that probably
is not actually on their to do list.
But I can't speak for them.
Retired but not expired, right?
Thank you so much for coming to hear me.
I appreciate it.
(applause)
(upbeat music)